allez on y va dans la classe de madame
barbier la rentrée se fait en chansons
pour ses 21 élèves c'est double niveau
cm1 cm2 une rentrée en douceur mais une
rentrée active
le principe c'est que dès qu'on commence
l'année et il faut tout de suite que les
enfants comprennent qu'elles seront les
attentes de l'enseignant tous les prend
en charge
il est important tu te marquer des
limites forte de manière après nous
pourrons assouplir les règles
cet établissement de guyancourt accueil
117 élèves
si les écoliers ont retrouvé leur classe
ce matin les professeurs sont sur le
pont depuis la semaine dernière on
prévoit tout ce qui est organisation de
l'école
donc tout ce qui est récréation au
planning de récréation planning de de
sport est ici d'organiser au mieux les
informations qu'on a des anciens anciens
enseignants pour les transmettre aux
nouveaux deux professeurs ont intégré
cette équipe des stagiaires qui ont
réussi le concours 2018
ils sont près de 400 pour le département
des yvelines
c'est plus important que l'année
dernière notre département et évolue
dans sa démographie
alors assez peu pour le premier degré
puisque en fait cette année
cette rentrée présente on attend moins
d'élèves que l'année dernière c'est un
passage
un passage à vide mais nous avons besoin
de nouveaux professeurs et nous en
accueillons plus d'une cinquantaine de
plus comparativement à l'année dernière
je m'y attendais pas forcément mais
quand j'ai vu mon nom sur la liste eh
bah c'était un soulagement du travail
avant d'en arriver là
excitation et un petit peu de stress
aussi bonne balance entre les deux elle
les élèves et professeurs sont partis
pour une nouvelle année scolaire
cette semaine de travail avant la
première pause les vacances de la
toussaint